l'argent qui reste le principal verrou
de la porte des vacances un français sur
deux ne part pas un été la moitié des
français privés de vacances pour raisons
économiques
ce constat en 1981 va pousser le
ministre du temps libre à mettre en
place les chèques-vacances un système
encadré par une agence publique l'agencé
nationale des chèques vacances et
financés par l'employeur et par le
salarié
notre ambition de faire en sorte que
plusieurs millions de familles à revenus
très modestes ce sont ceux là qui nous
contenus qui seront d'abord concerné qui
jusqu'ici ne prennent pas de vraies
vacances ne partent pas en vacances
puissent le faire un moyen d'aider les
départs en vacances mais pas que les
commissions perçues par l' agence
publique auprès des employeurs et des
professionnels du tourisme serviront à
financer la construction de centres de
vacances à aider des associations qui
permettent aux enfants défavorisés de
partir quelques semaines bref c'est un
cercle vertueux en faveur du tourisme
social
le chèque vacances va représenter non
seulement cet élément d'incitation pour
le départ en vacances de beaucoup de
gens qui le chouette mais en même temps
le moyen de récupérer de réunir des
sommes extrêmement importantes qui
serviront à l'investissement social les
chèques vacances sont dans un premier
temps réservé aux familles à faible
revenu et peu d'entreprises le propose
en 1984 deux ans après son lancement
seulement 5000 familles en bénéficient
mais pourtant déjà les bénéfices
potentiels d'un tel système font des
envieux dans le secteur privé en 1986 le
secrétaire d'état au tourisme du
gouvernement de jacques chirac propose
de libéraliser les chèques vacances
la formule l'exploitation de cette idée
n'a pas été bonne et
je me préoccupe actuellement de trouver
une formule plus libérale des aides à la
personne
à l'image par exemple de ce qui a été
fait pour les chèques restaurant
privatiser l' agence publique des
chèques vacances
il ne sera pas le dernier à le souhaiter
les entreprises privées qui gère déjà
les tickets restaurants sont dans les
starting blocks car les années passent
et l'utilisation des chèques vacances se
démocratise
mais l'agent ce public résiste c'est un
outil public voulue par l'état
permettant aux salariés de partir en
vacances
le magot générés par les commissions est
de plus en plus gros car dans les années
2010 ce sont près de 4 millions et demi
de français qui utilisent ces chèques
vacances
le chèque vacances représentent 5
milliards d'euros de retombées
économiques
en trente ans il a su s'imposer comme un
moteur du tourisme en france
aujourd'hui le gouvernement songe à
réformer lagence public en l'ouvrant à
des opérateurs privés
les salariés de l'agencé nationale pour
les chèques-vacances craignent que la
privatisation menace le cercle vertueux
mise en place et que les commissions ne
servent plus à financer du tourisme
social
mais des actionnaires
[Musique]